[Music]
i've been in this situation before
i was rescued from boats two times
these people wouldn't choose to do this
it's dangerous
but they feel like they have no choice
viewing these images the latest group of
migrants intercepted in the english
channel today
is clearly a struggle for this young
asylum seeker
rami made a similar journey just eight
months ago
forced to enter the uk illegally he says
because he was fleeing for his life
and there was no other option we lost
many good family members
in syria the people who are still alive
are the ones who left syria
my house was bombed i had to leave my
wife and daughter
thankfully they are still alive but i
have not seen them for three years
the flow of migrants attempting to cross
the channel by small boats is relentless
almost 250 yesterday dozens again today
the home secretary's planned solution
will effectively mean those who cross
illegally
will join the back of the queue when it
comes to claiming asylum
for the first time whether people enter
the uk
legally or illegally will have an impact
on how their asylum claim progresses
and on their status in the uk if that
claim is successful
these changes risk making the situation
even worse
for victims of human trafficking as it
would be even
harder to access help in the uk helping
criminal gangs
escape justice rami says no asylum
seeker wants to break the law
but for many it's the choice between
life and death
people are desperate this is not going
to stop people coming here
for those crossing the channel it's
often the only way they can reach the uk
they don't have the luxury of seeking a
safe route
what she's doing is judging asylum
seekers on the way they are arriving
which is wrong in dunkirk the makeshift
camp here is still
full of those who dream of reaching uk
shores
one young kurdish man told us whatever
pretty patel
says he still plans to make the crossing
we have only two way but or other one
so what we should do we are an
immigration person
people you know see much person is here
and
also they want to go into uk
in south end neuron is one of the lucky
ones
accepted onto the vulnerable persons
resettlement scheme
the type of program the home secretary
wants other asylum seekers to use
but neurons says that type of program
simply isn't open to the majority of
asylum seekers
it's very sad very upsetting even
sometimes
i feel guilty for coming in a safe
safer ways than they are but and then i
think it's not my fault
it's the government's fault they don't
want to take these routes but they have
to
because they don't have a choice they
want they don't want to die they don't
want their children to die
they want to save their lives the home
secretary clearly believes she has
widespread public support for her
crackdown
but implementing those plans is likely
to be far from
easy with human rights groups already
talking about taking legal action to
stop them
mark white sky news